peace be with you welcome to the Dean
show subscribe if you have not already
we know that there's a growing trend
rise of Islamophobia but did you know
that to be anti-islam is to be anti
Jesus did you know to be anti-islam is
to be end time Moses you're probably
wondering how is that well that's why
you've tuned into the Dean show and
you're going to stay tuned in because we
have the answers to many of the things
that's been on your mind and someone's
guided you to watch the right show so we
can unclear the mind and hopefully you
have a totally new perspective back in a
moment with my guess who's been battling
this Islamophobia for some time so we're
going to be right back here on the Dean
show don't go anywhere this is please be
with you or salam alayka honey comes
down how are you sheikh imam dr. Morsi
how are you hamdullah thank you for
having me I'm very happy to be here how
is it in the sunny state of Florida it's
it's sunny it's hot but they're talking
about some Airport prayer room tell us
about this well we have been working
with the airport authority at the
Orlando International Airport to provide
prayer space for Muslim travelers and
Orlando gets over 55 million visitors
each year and of course many of those
are Muslims who travel to the
attractions at Walt Disney World and
SeaWorld and universal studios kennedy
space center so they find it difficult
especially in the international terminal
not to have place to pray and we have
asked the airport authorities to as part
of their customer service and the
enhancement of that service to provide
the space for traveling muslims and they
have responded positively and they have
prepared a nice space for that which
created a little bit of a firestorm for
anti Muslim groups who see Islam in a
very negative way and think that the
airport authority was wrong to make such
a space even though we said that that
space would be also open to all faith
communities for anyone who wants to pray
to god there's space we are not trying
to be exclusive but we believe that a
lot of passengers you know over eighty
percent of people in the world they
believe in God and they want that time
to pray so it's a natural thing for the
airport to do it there are many airports
like O'Hare like JFK like Heathrow like
Frankfurt mr. damn they all have spaces
for prayers so the traveler can really
find time to to talk to God now when I
opened up the show I talked about to be
anti-islam to be is to be anti Jesus to
be anti-islamist be on time Moses I'll
get into that question in a moment but
for the person that hears now prayer
room in an airport and you're like this
doggone Muslims and they got the Sharia
now in the airports and they're taking
over have you heard some of this
rhetoric I heard that rhetoric but has
nothing to do with sherry are taking
over the airport the airport has spaces
for people to eat has spaces for people
to use the restroom has playgrounds for
kids because when you have to wait for
two hours sometimes more to catch your
flight and that's a time of anxiety time
of nervousness you go through security
you may have forgotten something and
with all the news we hear about people
you know dying on flights flights are
crashing around the world so people are
not all you know very happy to be on a
flight they are nervous prayer is a way
for the traveler to be
calm to be prepared for a long journey
and that actually helps the people at
the airport other passengers it helps
the security at the airport and we feel
that everybody is should be given the
permission to pray you know and it has
nothing to do with taking over the
airport or implementing sure yeah
doggone it if I want to pray I want to
pray and yeah I'm prayed to it'd
probably be better for you now it's
better you would get away it rich
somebody's hatred in your heart yes and
doctors tell you that it is healthy for
it's better for your house to pray so
that you put your trust in God and
things will be okay and you go on your
journey with that trust and you don't
have to be a nervous wreck when you
board so a Muslim free zone do they got
is this happening out in Florida in
Florida too what's going on how can you
I mean at one point it was like a black
free zone get to the back of the bus and
now were they trying to do this to
Muslims well in reaction to the tragic
events in China to guess and Tennessee
where a so-called Muslim went on a
shooting rampage some of those anti
Muslim groups also went out to try to
express their anger by creating these
Muslim free zones they don't want to
sell to Muslims they don't want to deal
with Muslims simply because they don't
know Muslims they don't know Islam and
they don't understand Islam is peace and
we are citizens who love this country
and we are willing to defend it but the
rhetoric they hear on television on the
radio all the time from groups that
really don't like Islam to put it
bluntly army making a lot of Americans
nervous and leading to these kinds of
Muslim free zones and businesses free
zones that don't want Muslims to come
now many of our viewing audience if they
didn't get a chance because we've had
you some years ago on the show and you
actually tackle this head-on there was
actually a person who is try
to burn the quran Terri Jerry Jones
what's his name pastor Terry Jones yes
and you actually were the person that
was I had dialogue to to his church in
Gainesville Florida and to convince him
to cancel the quran burning that he had
planned and it was an event that
captured the international attention
media from all over the world and it led
to a lot of conflicts in afghanistan
other places where people really didn't
like what this pastor was doing but many
Christians great good Christians who
have asked him not to do it he wasn't
listening and I had to go to kill two
days consecutively and meet with him
while he was armed and dangerous to try
to convince him not to do it because
it's not good for anybody and thanks to
God I was successful and we had peaceful
eid at that time but some hate groups
convinced him several months later to do
it anyway and unfortunately it led to
what we feared people dying in
Afghanistan at the UN compound because
of his actions so we had this situation
whatever we got to go to break but we
want to find out what happened to this
pastor he was trying to burn the quran
and then how would you respond we got
someone trying to eat the quran this is
something also real crazy back with more
hannity show don't go anywhere the
question is about whether Muslims are
not good citizens the Constitution
defines what a good citizen is and the
preamble it says we the people of the
United States in order to form a more
perfect union establish justice insure
domestic tranquility sunni muslim they
can say that is a good
and most Muslims can say that most
Muslims will embrace that most persons
are good Americans this is the things is
the D
back here on the
Dean show and anti to be anti-muslim is
to be anti Jesus a bold statement we're
going to address this not yet okay what
happened to Terry Pastor Jones whatever
happened to him well first he lost his
church he moved from Gainesville went to
Pinellas County near Tampa Florida and
the last I know is he opened the fries
you know in a little shop in inside the
mall selling french fries so he was
trying to jump on board and the
Islamophobia industry trying to actually
take advantage yes and I didn't where he
was yeah exactly didn't work out he
printed t-shirts saying Islam is of the
devil he you know made mugs coffee mugs
he did everything to try to make money
out of Islamophobia but then you know
Americans turned their backs on him and
had that business venture failed so now
he is doing french fries you know I mean
that's what happens you know you spewing
hate your proponent of hate and you end
up being humiliated at the end exactly
yeah so tell us now we're going to go to
this clip we talked about him trying to
end up burning the quran this person
trying to eat the crime you will burn in
hell look at this you're always acting
like a real mozo get it hate oh okay you
got to see this disturbing clip I'm not
so you know you have these lunatics out
there who are trying to provoke you know
people these kids going to school we did
a show on this before I'm more concerned
that now when Muslims they end up
falling for this they end up maybe
acting inappropriately and then the
person says nah gotcha so the Muslim
will do something ignorant also in
response to ignorance so then the camera
will catch this and then you just made a
fool out of yourself you didn't help
you know the cause of propagating the
truth what advice do you have I think we
have seen for number of years now that
every few weeks some crazy person would
come out trying to provoke Muslims
either by doing you know caricature of
the prophet or writing an article to
insult Muslims or doing something you
know to show their distasteful attitude
towards the Quran or the prophet and
they have in the past succeeded in
provoking some Muslims and the media
loves to capture those provoke Muslims
and how they react negatively and they
overlook the provocateurs who brought
that situation to begin with my advice
to Muslims is the Prophet peace be upon
him was provoked but he was patient and
he did not get angry and as you know
when we fast if somebody provoke us the
Prophet said you should say I'm fasting
you should not fall for it you should
not respond in kind because that's not
Islam Islam means to be peaceful the
Muslim means the peaceful person and if
someone provokes you or insults you say
peace and move away do not respond to
this kind of madness you know in every
society there are fanatics there are
lunatics who act like this and it's not
our job to fix them or respond to them
we just have to say peace salon and move
away that's it I mean you're not going
to help the situation I mean you
shouldn't be cursing anyway exactly you
shouldn't be throwing a punch you
shouldn't be getting violent that's not
that's not going to help at all and it's
going to prove a point that they're
trying to make yeah and they time and
again they try to provoke us sometimes
they do a video about the prophets
sometimes they do caricature of the
prophet and we know our prophet we know
the Prophet wasn't anything like what
they're describing he was a man of peace
man of justice man of loving everyone
and we need to
be like him and not respond in kind to
these provocations have you had also
recently you've had some of these
organized efforts where people will
actually come with guns in front of the
houses of God of worship have you have
you seen us in Florida we had it in
Arizona recently we have seen it in
Arizona we had at our mosque group that
flew from Texas okay and organized in
front of the mosque in the right-of-way
and they had megaphones and they were
shouting and screaming just like the
video we saw you go into hell you're
going to burn in hell and all of these
provocations but it was in the height of
summer in July in Florida where you know
it's hundred degrees with hundred
percent humidity so I felt sorry for
them and i sent the volunteers with
water and lemonade i said these people
are going to pass out if you don't give
them some water so we don't respond in
kind we respond as muslims the way our
prophet taught us you know go to them
give them chilled water let them calm
down and understand that if they think
we're going to hell that's their opinion
they're in times of their opinion but we
know better we know that Islam is peace
and we have to live that piece when we
are dealing with our neighbor actually
when the Muslims invited you know about
this when they invited one of the some
of the key organizers into the mass
totally different totally a change of
heart exactly and that's the strategy
you need to know that these people are
ignorant they don't know what Islam is
so instead of arguing with them and
fighting with them invite them bring
them in feed them give them something to
drink let them dress let them see for
themselves our mosques are open to
everyone by the way the Prophet peace be
upon him invited Jewish rabbis into the
mosque he invited the Christians of
Nigerian to his mosque for days so we
have no restriction to invite
Muslims in we have nothing to hide we're
proud of where we pray to God and we're
not a secret society we are human beings
who love peace who love our neighbors
and everyone is welcome I encourage
everyone watching to please visit your
mask ok we'll give you personal tour and
answer all of your questions no
obligations free of charge just this is
our your right to know and our
obligation to open our hearts and homes
and mass to you now what you've been
waiting for when we come back answer in
the bold statement that being anti-islam
if you're a christian now is actually
anti Jesus when we come back here in the
Dean sure we're going to be clarifying
this don't go anywhere salam says love
all mankind that's why we're sharing
this message because we want the best
for you and we want the best for all
mankind please subscribe to the dvo
follow us on our official facebook and
twitter pages in the links below please
also help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the DS show now what they've been
waiting for gluten from the beginning is
said this guy said look man to be
anti-islam is to be anti Moses Jesus
Abraham and all the prophets is this a
true statement strew because the
religion that God had for Humanity's
Islam is peace Adam was a man of peace
Abraham Moses Jesus all of the prophets
were men of peace they were all calling
to God so if you go against one of them
you're going against all of them if you
say I'm against Muhammad well you are
against Jesus and Moses and Abraham and
Adam and hundreds of other prophets
because all of these prophets were not
calling people to themselves they were
calling people to the one true God Allah
and that's the unifying message for all
humanity we are not Islam is not a
religion for the Arabs it's not the
religion for the Turks it's a religion
for every human being it's a
relationship between you and God and
Jesus himself declared himself as a
Muslim Abraham
an ich mal they declared themselves as
Muslims in the Quran says what jalna
mostly mainly like make us muslims to
you which means to be at peace with you
Oh God and we have to understand that
there is one God one humanity and all of
these prophets as our leaders and
mentors and role models are in our faith
beloved Muslims that's amazing when you
really dissect the word Muslim one who
surrenders peacefully to the crater that
happens in earth and has pieces with his
crazy peaceful Society we're not trying
to harm nobody we say we open up the
show we said peace be with you exactly
and who's more embodies that than the
prophets themselves Mohammed Jesus Moses
Abraham they are the role models in
submitting to God and being at peace
with God I really think you know and
I've mentioned this before you know some
time not too long ago you had these
races bigots skinhead KKK people in the
White thobes now the white thobes it's
not cool to wear that anymore but now
that racism many that have inherited you
know because you're not born with this
hate you've taught it exactly so now
they just carrying over many people they
haven't figured out the purpose of life
they're angry with life and now just
looking for someone to hate on to blame
and as a nation the United States had
this problem for a long time with
different groups you know they hated the
Jews at one day they hated the Cubans
they hated the Mexicans they hate it you
know the African Americans and now it's
our turn they hate Muslims because they
understand Islam if you understand this
love I encourage everyone watching
please take the time and study Islam as
Siri you know on your phone tell me
about Islam go on Wikipedia read about
this lump on your own you know you don't
have to think about why just read it
inform yourself be an informed citizen
you will find for yourself that Islam is
peace Islam is love Islam is respect and
you will come around not to hate Muslims
and I don't want people of this great
nation to feel sorry one day in the
fusions
you know we have made a mistake as we
did with the African Americans and the
American Indians now learn today this
education this information is available
at your fingertips everywhere there's no
excuse to be ignore it anymore Islam is
a multi race every person from any
background is invited and it's simple
don't realize there is over 1.7 billion
Muslims according to the pew research
center and they are in every country in
every ethnic group every language there
are Muslims in every shape and color and
that is the fact Islam is not an Arabic
group it's LOM is a global faith a
global religion there was one politician
who he had his key researcher look into
Islam a lot of times they looked to try
to cherry-pick versus to try to use them
to incite fear but anyone who just opens
up the Koran reads the before and after
will see the context of these verses Oh
with this guy's saying his false but
this actually this person was actually
trying to ban the Koran his researcher
actually ended up accepting Islam did
you you heard about this guy I heard
about that and that's the beauty about
Islam people from afar they think Islam
is problem Islam is promoting terrorism
but when they read the Quran for
themselves and that's why I asked people
to read the Quran for themselves they
going to find it is beautiful it is
promoting peace and love among all human
beings in chapter 49 verse 13 God said
all people we created you from male and
female made you into nations and tribes
to come to know one another to love each
other to respect each other that's the
purpose the mission of Islam it's not to
divide us as people but to unite us as
human beings we share one world and we
should love and respect one another now
these people who cherry-pick the Quran
if they cherry pick the Bible they're
going to find a lot of horrible things
that they themselves don't agree with
and I say cherry-picking is not
consistent with logic you have to read
the before I
after you have to put things into
context and you will understand the
beautiful picture I often tell people
because obviously there is such thing as
a just war and when you look at the
verses that are talking about any kind
of battle I usually ask people I say
would you rather be in a fight with
rules or no rules so now when something
is about to go down in in a situation
where let's say you are running a
country how do you apply these verses
that now when someone looks at it and it
says Oh what this guy these are these
apologist apologetic Muslims and it says
you know kill them wherever you find
them you found me how he's lying to us
they're doing takia they're they're
deceiving us well Islam gives us clear
rules of engagement okay not to even in
war you cannot attack civilians you
cannot attack people in their religious
places you cannot cut down trees you
have to do your best to preserve the
peace now the enemies of peace they may
wage war on you Islam gives you the
right to defend yourself now tell me
which war that Christians have done is
according to the teachings of Jesus now
many Christians in this world if there
are true Christians and follow Jesus can
they actually go to work and they have
even a standing army but we know that
Europe went to war world war one world
war two the United States has the
strongest army in the world is this a
Christian value why they don't ask
themselves why do we have guns why do we
as a nation everybody has a gun on their
waist we have to understand that when we
accuse somebody of something we have to
look in the mirror and ask ourselves are
we the ones who are guilty of that there
are millions of American Muslims they
don't own guns they'd never fire the gun
and they don't have guns in their homes
because guns are tools to kill and we
don't wish to kill anybody that's really
the facts I mean when I the facts on the
ground yeah
and I like what you said so pick up the
Quran do some research would you say
also a good place to start is I mean
because we want to know why we've been
created the purpose of light is asking
sincerely if you pick up the Quran read
chapter 3 for example that talks about
Mary and Jesus and her family talks
about Christians in very beautiful terms
you will see the similarities if you
reach after 19 named miriam or Mary it
is again about the stories of Miriam and
Jesus the birth of Jesus the miracles
that's what we believe in we are
brothers we are close and Christians out
to themselves to open this book and see
it because if you just listen to someone
who accused the Quran of things you know
after nine eleven some people said oh
there is a verse in the Quran that
talked about 911 and that how it's false
the internet is full of wrong
information about Islam so you have to
read for yourself you have no excuse
today you read many books many novels
take this one book read it for yourself
and then you decide and people can visit
you at your mask any time any time I'll
give them personal tour how can now
people if they wanted to you tell us
about your organization people want to
get a contact with you anytime you are
in orlando florida going to this day
please call on us and come and visit we
will love to have you and we have open
houses all the time and we provide free
meals and we help our neighbors so we'd
love to have you we as i always conclude
i say look we the greeting of Jesus was
not hey what's up how you doing it was a
peace be with you exactly so we started
with peace we anything so I'm like
fellow Monica legs thank you thank you
and thank you for tuning in to the Dean
show against subscribe if you haven't
already pick up the quraían read it it's
not going to hurt you you can get one
for free 1 800 662 Islam and before you
learn islam from someone who's full of
hate spewing hate
I mean you did the right thing you tune
into the Dean show and you got a
different perspective and this will only
enlighten you it will only open your
mind and your heart and even at the end
if you don't agree with Islam the
message at least now you had come you
had investigated you have SAT with some
Muslims and you'd see that what you've
been taught is actually something that
is not true but you've actually opened
your mind you've been humble enough
because at the end what will happen if
you follow someone of hate you end up
just viewing more hate the heart girls
of hate and you just become bitter and
angry but at the end what happens you go
in like the gentleman did in Arizona
what struck me the most honestly was
when I took a minute to actually talk to
some of the Muslim people to find out
you know they are just like me and I am
uneducated on their religion you know I
could easily make as many mistakes
judgment calls as any other person out
there but when I took a second to sit
down and listen to them and actually
enter their mosque and going and watch
some of their prayers it was a beautiful
thing and he SAT with the Muslims he
came in there had a totally different
perspective and then the heart softens
and maybe even got a new friend so this
is what we need to do we need to go
ahead and build these bridges we need to
communicate with our brothers in
humanity share this with your neighbors
share this with your friends to continue
to tune in here to the D show we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you salam says love all mankind that's
why we're sharing this message because
we want the best for you and we want the
best for all mankind please subscribe to
the Biggio follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the V
show by making a donation in the link
below